un autre dossier épineux a été abordé ce
matin en conseil des ministres le projet
de loi sur l'enseignement privé a été
adopté par le gouvernement et les
réactions des protagonistes sont sans
surprise mais aussi sans enthousiasme et
celle gougy et dominique laurie les
textes concernant la carte scolaire et
la création d'établissements d'intérêt
public sont inchangés la seule précision
porte sur le financement des écoles
privées par les collectivités locales
pendant six ans l'état pourra se
substituer dans certaines conditions aux
communes un exemple une commune qui n'a
pas d'école privée sur son territoire
mais dont certains enfants fréquentent
l'école privée de la commune voisine
devra selon la future loi payer pour ses
enfants
toutefois comme il s'agit d'une dépense
supplémentaire pendant six ans la mairie
pourra demander l'aide de l'état
en ce qui concerne le projet de décret
sur la fonctionnarisation des maîtres
l'objectif demeure le même c'est à dire
possibilité de titularisation des
enseignants
après une période de six ans ce principe
n'est pas négociable
seules les modalités le son on nous a un
petit peu oublié
trop en tout cas même s'il y a eu un
certain nombre d'avancées sur les
problèmes de gestion de l'enseignement
privé
en tout cas demeure un problème
essentiel sur lequel nous ne pouvons pas
transiger qui est celui de l'obligation
faite aux commmunes maintenant au plus
tard ça ne change rien au niveau des
principes de subventionner à
l'enseignement privé particularistes des
confessionnelles donc les jeux sont
faits et vous allez manifester le 25
est ce que ça ne sera pas disons à un
baroud d'honneur ce ne sera pas un
baroud d'honneur en tout cas ça ne
saurait être que la fin d'une phase mais
j'ai le sentiment que c'est peut-être un
recommencement pour une autre phase
parce que le président de la république
ne peut pas désespérer ses militants les
plus fidèles et la gauche n'a pas le
droit de faillir à sa mission
il y est question de gestion
administrative il y est question de
gestion matérielle financière
mais l'essentiel pour nous n'est pas là
il est dans le statut des maîtres or
nous refusons la fonctionnarisation de m
oui mais vous vous trouvez maintenant
devant le fait accompli
la fonctionnarisation
être à terme aura bien lieu là dessus on
peut pas y revenir alors qu'allez vous
faire
bon nous allons poursuivre tout
l'arsenal juridique nécessaire
nous allons faire appel à l'opinion
publique car nous ne pouvons pas
admettre d'être assigné totalement
l'enseignement public
alors est ce qu'on peut parler déjà d'un
verre saïbi c'est ce que vous allez une
fois de plus mobilisés les gens dans la
rue
rien n'est décidé mais l'hypothèse n'est
pas exclue dans notre